Bu ders anlatacaklarımı çok iyi
dinlemeni istiyorum çünkü Levis
yapısından bahsedeceğim İyonik bağıda
kovalent bağda en iyi anlayabileceğin
yer buradan geçiyor burayı dikkatli bir
şekilde dinlersen İyonik ve kovalent bağ
artık daha kolay gelecek sana Bugün
anlatacağım kısım Levis yapısı Levis
elektron nokta yapısı bunlarla kovalent
bağlı bileşikler nasıl yazılıyor iyonik
bağlı bileşikler nasıl yazılıyor
bunlardan bahsedeceğim o zaman vakit
kaybetmiyoruz hazırsak başlayalım şimdi
Levis nokta yapısına geçmeden önce şunu
söylemem lazım element molekülleri veya
işte şik molekülleri veya bileşikler
Neyse artık bunların oluşması güçlü
etkileşimlerle meydana geliyordu işte
Son katmanındaki elektron sayısına
bakarak yapıyorduk yani değerlik
elektron sayılarına bakarak bir atomun
işte iyonik bağlı bileşik mi yapacak
kovalent bağlı bileşik mi yapacak
bunların kararını veriyorduk İşte
bunların noktasal olarak gösterme
şekline Biz Levis gösterim diyoruz Yani
bir element sembolünün çevresine
elementin değerlik elektronlarını nokta
şeklinde göstermeye Biz Levis yapısı ya
da Levis elektron nokta yapısı şeklinde
bir ifade kullanıyor
ya da Levis elektron gösterimi Peki
nasıl yapılıyor Şöyle yapıyorsun önce
bir elektron dizilimini yazıyorsun bir
tane örneklendir mesela mesela ne olsun
şeyi yazalım sodyumu yazalım mesela
sodyum 11 1 S2 2 S2 2p 6 3S 1 oldu değil
mi bunun değerlik elektronları
hangisidir son katmandaki bir elektron
değil mi yani İşte buna bakarak
yapıyorsun elementin sembolünü
yazıyorsun sodyum ve değerlik
elektronunu nokta şeklinde gösteriyorsun
başka bir tane gö göstereyim mesela 8
yazayım ne olsun 1 S2 2 S2 2p 4 şeklinde
belirttim sembolü yazıyorsun bunun
değerlik elektron sayısı yani valans
elektron sayısı 6 önce birer tane
yazıyorsun DT tarafına birer tane 1 2 3
4 sonra 5 6 bu şekilde artık 4 tane
birer tane yazdıktan sonra 4 tane işte
bir nokta yazdıktan sonra diğerlerini
yanlarına eklemeye başlıyorsun 6 olduğu
için bu şekilde belirttim bir tane daha
yazayım mesela mesela ne olsun FL olsun
9 1 S2 2 S2 2p 5 bunun değerlik elektron
sayısı 7 floru Yazdım 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 bu
şekilde gösteriyoruz dostum hemen Bak
burada örnek var Ne vermiş burada
alüminyum vermiş değerlik elektron
sayısı kaç 3 yazıyorsun işte alüminyum
sembolünü yazdın Sonra birer tane
noktayı bu şekilde 3 tarafına koyduk 4
tarafı var ama 3 tane olduğu için bu
şekilde 3ç tarafına koymuş olduk burada
ne var görüyor musun fosfor var değerlik
elektron sayısı b 5 O zaman ne yapmam
lazım 5 nokta önce birer tane yazıyorsun
1 2 3 4 sonra birinin yanına ikinciyi
ekliyorsun Şimdi burada önemli bir
detaydan bahsedeceğim buradaki tek
noktalar var ya bak şunlar ikili
noktalar ikili nokta ikili nokta her bir
yönde ikili nokta varsa bunlar bağ
yapmıyordur tek başına bulunan nokta
sayısı kadar bağ yapar bir atom Onu
yazayım şöyle yapalım bir atom Levis
yapısındaki tek nokta sayısı kadar bağ
yapabilir tabii ki farklı örnekleri var
gene olarak Bunu söylüyoruz Yoksa bu
Levis yapısındaki tüm noktaları
kullanarak bağ yapanlar da var ama genel
bir ifadedir bu çok faydasını görürsün
mesela gel Şurayı yapalım şimdi hidrojen
neydi 1 S 1'di yani değerlik elektron
sayısı 1'di o zaman bir tane noktayı
koyduk helyumu sonra göstereceğim
lityuma Bak 1 S2 2 S1 değerlik elektron
sayısı 1'di bir tane nokta koyduk
Berilyum Bak 1 S2 2 S2 değerlik elektron
sayısı 2 olduğu için 2 tane nokta koyduk
iki noktayı birbirinden uzak yer yerlere
yerleştirdik diyebilirsin hocam helyumda
da iki tane nokta olacak 1 S2 bunları
niye böyle yapmadık ne demiştim bak
Yukarıya geldim bir atom Levis
yapısındaki tek nokta sayısı kadar bağ
yapar helyum neydi
soygazdan mı yapmaz işte eğer bak
helyumu böyle yazarsam 2i bağ yapar gibi
bir durum ortaya çıkıyor Yanlış mesela
hidrojen bir bağ yapacaktır lityum 1 bağ
yapacaktır Berilyum 2 bağ yapacaktır 2A
grubu Bor 3 bağ yapacaktır işte karbon 4
bağ azota bakalım 3 tane tek nokta var
görüyor musun Bak şöyle 1 2 3 tane tek
nokta var 3 bağ yapar oksijende iki tane
tek nokta var iki bağ yapar fla bir tane
tek nokta var bir bağ yapar neonda tek
nokta yok Hep ikili görüyor musun O
yüzden bu bağ yapmaz e aynı durum helyum
için de geçerli O yüzden helyumun
noktalarını yan yana yazıyorsun tamam mı
dostum Şimdi bir de iyonlarda Levis
yapısı yazmak var ki burada çok güzel
bir şey var metaller ne yapar elektron
verir değil mi Hangi elektron verir
değerlik elektronlarını Şöyle
örneklendir mesela sodyum 11 dedim 1 S2
2 S2 2p 6 3 S1 değil mi bunun Levis
yapısı şöyleydi şu şekilde gözüküyordu
tek nokta Peki sodyum kararlı olmak için
ne yapacaktır bir elektron verecektir
yani 1 S2 2 S2 2 P6 oldu bak değerlik
elektronunu verdi Sonuçta Levis yapısı
da sadece değerlik noktaları şeklinde
yazıldığı için yani değerlik
elektronlarını yazdığımız için sodyum
burada işte o bir elektronu verdi ya
gidip de Aa şimdi 8 tane var Ben buna
8iz tane nokta koyayım şeklinde sakın
düşünme yanlış yaparsın değerlik
elektronunu verdiği için gitti üzeri + 1
ne köyşehir parantez ne bir şey artı
yüklüler de nokta silersin eksi yüklüler
de nokta ilavesi yaparsın bir tane daha
artı yüklü göstermek istiyorum mesela
magnezyum 12 diyelim 1 S2 2 S2 2 P6 3
s2d bunun Levis yapısı iki tane nokta bu
şekilde gözükür ama magnez soygaza
benzemek için iki elektron verecek ki
şunu unutma metaller soygaza
benzediğinden elektron verip bir üstteki
soygaza benzerler Bak bu 2 elektron
verdi değil mi 12'ye + 2 oldu 1 S2 2 S2
2 P6 oldu 3 periyotu ama nereye benzedi
ikinci periyot soygazın benzedi Yani
kendinden önceki soygaza benzeyecek
metaller ve Ne oldu magnezyum iki tane
değerlik elektronunu verdiği için bu
şekilde yazıldı alt katmanı yazmıyoruz
değerlik elektronlarını kaybettiği için
var olan noktaları kaybettiği için
onları sildik ve üzerine yükü yazdık ama
eksi yüklü olsaydı mesela flor 9 flor 9
1 S2 2 S2 2p 5'te soygaza benzemek için
ne yapmak ister bir tane elektron almak
ister flor bir tane elektronu aldığında
Ne oldu 9 -1 oldu 10 elektronu olacak
yani 1 S2 2 S2 2 P6 oldu bak flor şuydu
Normalde 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 nokta vardı
böyleydi e dışarıdan bir elektron aldı
ya şu öyle olacak Bak 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
vardı 8 elektronu aldı şuraya ve köşeli
parantez üzeri -1 yani eksi yüklü
olduğunda nokta ilavesi yapıp köşeli
parantez üzerine yük yazıyorsun artı
yüklüler de nokta silip sadece üzerine
yük yazıyorsun köşeli parantez falan yok
bir örnek daha yazacağım Buraya mesela
azotu yazayım azot 7 1 S2 2 S2 2p 3'tür
soygaza benzemek şimdi 3 elektron almak
isteyecek Normalde bunun Levis yapısı bu
şekildeydi şöyle duruyordu e azot
soygaza benzemek için ne yaptı 3
elektron aldı 1 S2 2 S2 2p 6'ya dönüştü
Normalde 5 noktası vardı şu şekilde 5
noktası vardı Dışarıdan da 3 tane aldı
onları da yanına yazdık köşeli parantez
üzeri -3 şeklinde yazdık soygazlara
benzemek için demek ki ametaller kendi
periyodundaki soygaza benziyor neydi
ikinci periyottadır ikinci periyot
soygazın Benzi benzedi ama metaller bir
üstteki periyodun soygazın benziyor
tamam mı dostum Mesela bak burada örnek
vermiş İşte alüminyumun K neydi Normalde
3 tane noktası vardı al 1 2 3 3 elektron
verdiğinde işte onlar gidecek O noktalar
gidecek alüminyum + 3 bunun Levis yapısı
bu kadar ama eksi yüklüler de fosfor
neydi 5A grubuyuz Normalde 1 2 3 4 5'i e
dışarıdan 3 tane elektron aldı -3 yüklü
olacak ya soygaza benzemek için e köşeli
parantez üzerine -3 yazdık dostum burada
da bak bazı örnekler ver işte Ne olmuş
1A grubu + 1 değerlik alıyor zaten
değerlik elektron sayısı 1'di ne oldu
işte lityuma örnek vermiş lityum 1
elektron verdi Aha bu şekilde gözüktü 2A
grubunda mesela Berilyum vardı 2 noktası
vardı + 2 olunca o 2'yi kaybetti direkt
yazdık Bor mesela 3A grubuyuz şöyle 3
tane noktası vardı gitti bu şekilde
gösterdik 4A grubu bak -4 diyor 4
elektron aldı Normalde 1 2 3 4 vardı 4
de dışarıdan aldı Ne olacak bu şekilde
yapıp köşeli par üzeri -4 yazdık e 5A
grubu Normalde 5A grubunda 5 tane nokta
vardı 1 2 3 4 5 böyle duruyordu 3 tane
aldı bu şekle geldi oksijen 6 nokta var
mesela 1 6a grubu ya 2 3 4 5 6'yı
böyleydi dışarıdan 2 tane alınca bu hale
gelmiş oldu e 7A grubuna floru vermiş
mesela 1 2 3 4 5 6 7'di dışarıdan bir
tane aldı -1 oldu bu şekilde gösterdik
8A grubu nötrdür zaten soygazdan var Aha
bu şekilde zaten gözüküyor köşeli
parantez Olsa da olur olmasa da olur gel
o zaman bak örnekler diyor Yukarıdaki
taneciklerden hangilerinin Levis yapısı
doğru verilmiştir diyor Şimdi burada ne
var azot var azot 7 değil mi 1 S2 2 S2
2p 3'tü değerlik elektron sayısı 5'i 1 2
3 4 bir tanesinin yanına ikinciyi koyduk
5 O zaman bu doğru magnezyum nasıl
yazılıyordu magnezyum şöyle şuraya
yazalım 1 S2 2 S2 2 P6 3S 2di 2A grubu
değerlik elektron sayısı 2 olduğu için 2
nokta var Bu da bu şekilde gösterilir
Doğrudur oksijene bakalım 1 S2 2 S2 2p
4'tü Normalde 1 2 3 4 5 6 nokta vardı -2
diyorsa dışarıdan 2 tane elektron aldı o
zaman köşeli parantez üzeri -2 şeklinde
olur yani bu da doğru bir
gösterimdeki buraya bakalım Diyor ki
Yukarıdaki atom ve iyonların Levis
gösterimlerinde nokta sayılarının
karşılaştırılması şimdi magnezyum 12'ye
+ 2 Normalde magnezyum 12 dediğimizde
neydi 1 S2 2 S2 2 P6 3S 2'ydi Yani şöyle
bulunuyordu şu şekildeydi ama o 2
elektronu verdiği için magnezyum + 2
oldu yani bunun nokta sayısı 0 s -2 var
mesela S16 1 S2 2 S2 2p 6 3s 2 3 p 4'tü
s'nin Normalde 1 2 3 4 5 6 noktası vardı
-2 diyor o zaman 2 tane daha ilave ettik
köşeli parantez üzeri -2 Yani bunun
nokta sayısı ne oldu 8 oldu değil mi
bana onu soruyor nokta sayısını soruyor
flor 9 diyor Bakalım 1 S2 2 S2 2p 5i 7
nokta olacak değerlik elektron sayısı 7
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 E o zaman nokta sayılarını
karşılaştırırsak 2 3 1 olacak var mı
bakıyoruz 2 3 1 cevap da e seçeneği
şimdi iyonik bileşiklerde Levis yapısı
nasıl yazılır kovalent bileşiklerde
nasıl yazılır bunlardan bahsedelim
İstersen şöyle bir şey var Neydi iyonik
bağlı bileşiklerde metaller elektron
veriyordu ametaller elektron alıyordu
kime örnek vermiş burada Bak mesela
sodyum klorür örnek vermiş sodyum neydi
1 S2 2 S2 2 P6 3S 1'di Yani bunun Levis
yapısı şöyleydi + 1 yüklü hale
geldiğinde Levis yapısı ne olacak + 1 bu
şekilde olacak E Klor neydi 7A grubu
elementiyle e kararlı Hale gel için
dışarıdan bir tane alacak soygaza
benzediğinden E ne olacak 1 2 3 4 5 6
7'di 88'e tamamlanmış olacak üzeri -1
oldu şimdi artı ve eksi sayısını
eşitlemek için ne yapıyorduk formüle
bakıyorduk şimdi bu na + 1 CL -1 yükler
toplamı 0 mı 0 o zaman demek ki bu
bileşik na cym miş birer tane kullandık
Peki Levis yapısı nedir derse İşte bu
Levis yapılarını yan yana yazıyorsun
sodyum artı böyle yazılıyor Klor eksi
böyle yazılıyor Al sana na cln Levis
yapısı dostum mesela mgcl2 diyor şimdi
magnezyum 1 S2 2 S2 2 P6 3 s2d Yani
normalde şöyleydi ama kararlı olduğunda
2 elektron verdi magnezyum + 2'ye
dönüştü e Klor neydi Klor 1 2 3 4 5 6
7'di -1 oldu Yani dışarıdan bir tane
aldı 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 oldu ve üzeri -1
oldu şimdi bak magnezyum + 2 Klor -1
artı ve eksi sayısını eşitlem lazım yani
Bun bir tane alıyorsam bundan iki tane
almam lazım ki artı ve eksi sayıları
eşit olsun mgcl 2 olmalı benim bileşiğin
değil mi artı eksi sayısını eşitlem için
böyle yapmam gerekiyor demek ki Levis
yapısında bir tane mg olacak Şundan bir
tane olacak o zaman iki tane de cli
olacak yani şundan iki tane olacak bu
şekilde yazabiliyoruz ya da bazı
kaynaklarda şöyle de görebilirsin mg + 2
2 tane CL - şeklinde gösterilebilir Bu
da doğrudur Öteki de doğrudur dostum
Şuraya bir ek örnek yapmak istiyorum
mesela alüminyum 13 ile alüminyum 13 ne
olsun işte 1 S2 2 S2 2p 6 3 S2 3 P1
kararlı olunca ne yapacak 3 elektron
verecek + 3 yüklü olacak 1 S2 2 S2 2 P6
olacak ki Levis yapısı elektron verdiği
için bu şekilde olacak mesela oksijenle
yaptığını düşünsek 1 S2 2 S2 2p 4 e
kararlı olmak için ne yapar dışarıdan 2
elektron alır 1 S2 2 S2 2p 6'ya dönüşür
şöyle Normalde 6 tane noktası vardı
şöyleydi Dışarıdan da 2 tane aldı üzeri
-2 oldu şimdi alüminyum + 3 oksijen -2
alınan verilen elektron sayısı eşit
olacak yani artı kaçsa eksi de o kadar
olacak ki sıfırlansın şundan ik tane
alsam Şundan da 3 tane alsam İkisi de
biri + 6 biri -6 sıfırlanmış oldu yani
bu bileşik al2 o3 olacak Demek ki Levis
yapısı da şöyle olacak 2 tane al + 3 3
tane de oksijen -2'den alırsak Al sana
İşte bu bileşiğin Levis yapısı diyoruz
moleküllerde Levis yapısı dediğimizde ya
da kovalent bağlı bileşiklerde Levis
yapısı dediğimizde ortak kullanılıyor
böyle köşeli parantezler eksiler artılar
orada yok Bunu sakın unutma burada işte
söylüyor atomlar arasında ortak
kullanılan elektronlar atomların
sembolleri etrafında işte çiftler
şeklinde gösteriliyordu yani aralarında
böyle iki atomun arasında gösteriliyordu
bu elektronlara bağlayıcı elektronlar ya
da ortaklanmış el elektron çifti
ifadesini kullanıyoruz ki hidrojenden
örnek vereyim hidrojenin bir tane
noktası vardı neden hidrojen Çünkü 1s
1'di E bir tane noktası olduğu için
değerlik elektron sayısı 1 olduğu için
böyle ik tane hidrojen H2 molekülünü
oluşturacaksınız
vardı diğerinin de bir tane ihtiyacı
vardı Bu da yani bir bağ yapmak istiyor
diğer hidrojen de bir bağ yapmak istiyor
işte onlar ortak kullanıyor ne demiştik
ortak kullanılan her elektron çifti bir
bağ demekti onu işte ne yapıyorduk böyle
gösterebiliyor olduk ya da bu şekilde
işte Bun buna Biz ne diyoruz bağlayıcı
ya da ortaklanmış elektron çifti
ifadesini kullanıyorduk mesela F2
olsaydı F2 molekülünde flor 9 1 S2 2 S2
2p 5'i Yani bunun 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 noktası
var tek nokta sayısı kadar bağ yapıyor
yani flor bir bağ yapmak isteyecek e F2
molekülünde diğer flor da bir bağ yapmak
isteyecek yani şöyleydi şu şu şekilde
duruyor diğer flor da diyor ki abi Bende
de bir tane var diyor gel or kullanalım
Aha bu şekilde oluşturuyorlar bak şuna
Biz ne diyoruz işte bağlayıcı elektron
çifti diyoruz E peki diğerleri ne dur
şöyle göstereyim şu şu şu Bunlar bağa
katılmadı değil mi İşte bunlara da hatta
aynısı Şurada da geçerli bunlara da
bağlayıcı olmayan ki genel olarak
ortaklaşması dostum o zaman gel tek tek
moleküllerden bahsedelim işte hidrojen
neydi birdi Levis yapısında bir nokta
vardı bununla bu ortak kullanacak
elektronları ortak kullandığı işte şöyle
gösterebilir veya şöyle gösterebiliriz
buna bağlayıcı elektron çifti ifadesini
kullanıyoruz F2 molekülünü söylemiştim
bir bağ yapmak istiyor Bu da bir bağ
yapmak istiyor Aha bak işte aralarında
bir tane bağ yaptılar ister böyle göster
ister dik şekilde göster ister böyle
bunlara Biz ne diyoruz bağlayıcı
elektron çifti diyoruz şunlar ne
oluyordu şunlar da şöyle ortaklaşması
tek noktası var Hatta şöyle şu renkle
göstereyim bak iki tane tek noktası var
iki bağ yapmak istiyor İkisi de o zaman
diyor ki Gel sen iki elektronunu getir
ben de ik elektronunu getireyim Aha Ne
yaptılar bak ortak kullanılan elektron
sayısı 4 Yani iki tane bağlayıcı
elektron çifti var Bu da ik bağ demektir
şunlar ne oluyordu
ki 3 tane tek noktası olduğu için 3 bağ
yapmak isteyecek O zaman iki tane Azot
atomu arasında Toplam 3 bağ yapıldı
şunlar da diğer elektronları bu şekilde
gösteriyoruz Bak burada yine
hatırlatayım burada Azot ne yapacak
şöyle bakarsak oktetini tamamladı toplam
8 elektron ortak kullanılanlar ikisine
de sayılır e haliyle diğer azotta ne
yapacaktır oktetini tamamlamış olacaktır
HF molekülünde ise bak hidrojenin Levis
yapısı buydu florun Levis yapısı ise 7
tane noktaydı 7A grubunda olduğu için
hidrojen de bir bağ yapmak istiyor flor
da bir bağ yapmak istiyor Diyor ki abi
gel biz bunları ortak kullanalım diyor
şunları bir araya getirelim E ne
yapıyorlar bir araya Getiriyorlar bak
bağlayıcı elektron çifti ister şöyle
göster ister şu şekilde yaz ya da araya
iki nokta şeklinde de gösterebilirsin
şunlar neydi
ortaklaşması elektron çifti Bu da
bağlayıcı elektron çifti oluyor H2O
molekülünde hidrojen bir bağ yapmak
istiyor oksijen 2 bağ yapmak istiyor o
zaman ne yapıyor şunu unutma önemli bir
şeyden bahsedeceğim böyle çok atomlu
moleküllerde Merkez atom bağ sayısı
fazla olandır Bak bu iki bağ yapmak
istiyor bunlar bir bağ yapmak istiyor ya
Merkez atom oksijen olacaktır yani
diğerleri oksijene bağlanmak
isteyecektir E ne oldu o zaman bak
hidrojenin birisi geldi bu oksijenin
şeyine bağlandı o tek noktasına E bu da
geldi Buraya bağlandı Aha bak şunları
oluşturdu bağlayıcı elektron çiftleri
bunu şöyle de gösterebilirim mesela şu
şekilde de gösterebilirim şunlar
verilenler diğerleri ise bağlayıcı
elektron çifti ya da ortaklanmış
elektron çifti şeklinde söylenecektir
CO2 molekülünde ise bak Karbonun 4 tane
tek noktası olduğu için bu 4 bağ yapmak
isteyecek oksijenin 2 tane tek noktası
olduğu için 2 bağ yapmak isteyecek O
zaman karbon diyor ki kardeş ben 4 bağ
yapmak istiyorum oksijen Sen 2 bağ
yapmak istiyorsun CO2 molekülünden
bahsediyorsak o zaman diyor ki gel
ikisini seninle paylaşayım ikisini de
seninle paylaşayım Böylelikle Ben 4
bağımı yapmış oldum Sen de 2 bağını
yapmış oldun Oh mis şunlar da zaten bağ
oluş olumuna katılmayan elektronlar yani
bağlayıcı olmayan elektronlar ne oldu
işte şunlar şu ikililer bağ yapmıyordu
tekliler bağ yapıyordu oksijendeki Erden
dolayı burada Toplamda 4 çift şöyle
yazalım e Hatta
ortaklaşması derse çifti değil sayısı
derse 8 aynı şekilde bağlayıcı elektron
çifti burada 1 2 3 4'tür ama bağlayıcı
elektron sayısı deseydi 8 diyecek şimdi
bakalım örnekte ne diyor Aşağıdaki
maddelerden hangisinin Levis yapısı
yanlış verilmiştir CO2 neydi karbon 4
tane tek noktası vardı şöyleydi yazayım
As altlarına şöyle hidrojen böyleydi
Berilyum 2A grubu 1 S2 2 S2 den dolayı
bu 2 bağ yapmak isteyecek karbon 1 S2 2
S2 2 P2 yani 4A grubuyuz 4 tane tek
noktası olacak azot neydi 1 S2 2 S2 2 P3
yani 5A grubuyuz 5 tane tekno şey
noktalar olacak 5 noktası olacak tek
nokta değil oksijene baktığımızda L bir
dakika Dur şu karıştı He oksijen 6a
grubu 1 2 3 4 5 6 Bu da 2 bağ yapmak
istiyor sodyuma geldiğimizde 1 S2 2 S2 2
P6 3 S1 di Yani bir tane noktası var Onu
da böyle gösterdik ve kükürt 1 S2 2 S2 2
P6 3 S2 3p 4'tü yani 6a grubu 1 2 3 4 5
6 bu şekilde yazdık şimdi karbon 4 bağ
yapmak istiyor oksijen 2 bağ yapmak
istiyorsa o zaman Bunlar karbona
bağlanmalıyız bağ sayısı fazla olan
merkezde olur ve bunun Levis yapısı bu
şekilde gözükmeli burada oksijen 4 bağ
yapmış oluyor Oh artık daha neler yani
Olur mu öyle şey bu yanlış yanlışı
bulduk Ama diğerlerine bakalım h2s diyor
bak S kaç 6a Grubu 2 bağ yapmak istiyor
hidrojen 1 bağ yapmak istiyor Aha bak
şunlar yaptı şöyle oldu aslında
hidrojenle şeyler S'ler bağ yaptı şunlar
da katılmadı Tamam bu doğru oksijen
üzeri -2 oksijende 6 nokta vardı İki
tane de dışarıdan aldı -2 dediği için ik
tane ekledik Tamam bu da olur na2o Bak
bu iyonik bileşik neden metalle ametal
na ne yapar sodyum bir elektron verir
sodyum + 1'e dönüşür oksijen 2 elektron
olur oksijen - 2'ye dönüşür yani Levis
yapısı bu şekilde olur e birisi + 1
birisi -2 na2o dediği için 2 tane sodyum
bir tane oksijen Evet gösterim Doğrudur
Berilyum 2A Grubu 2 nokta olmalı Bu da
Doğrudur biz yanlışı zaten kafadan
bulmuştuk cevap A seçeneğidir burada
bakalım ne diyor CL - ve N2 molekülleri
için şimdi hangileri diyor ki CL2
molekülünde daha büyüktür şimdi azot 1
S2 2 S2 2p 3 olduğu için 5A grubu
elementi Levis yapısı bu şekilde klora
bakarsak Eğer 1 S2 2 S2 2p 6 3 S2 3p
5'tir 7A grubudur yani 7 tane nokta
olmalıdır onu da bu şekilde belirtiyorum
şimdi ne diyor N2 ve CL2 şimdi CL Bir
tane tek noktası olduğu için bir bağ
yapacak Çok güzel diğer noktaları
çevresine gösteriyorum çift olanları
böyle yazıyorum tekler bağ yapıyor e
azotun tekte bulunan 1 2 3 tane tek
noktası var o zaman N2 molekülü 3 bağ
yapacaktır ve bağ yapmayanları da şunlar
bağ yapmayanlar Bak şöyle tek nokta
olanlar da şunlar görüyor musun Bunlar
da bağı yapanlar He o zaman baktığımızda
diyor ki ortaklanmış elektron çifti
ortaklanmış elektron çifti Aslında bağ
sayısıdır bağ sayısı bunda bir tane Ama
bunda 1 2 3 tane o yüzden bu N2 de daha
büyüktür olmadı ortaklanmamış elektron
çifti yani bağ yapmayan elektron çifti 2
4 6 8 10 12 tane bunda var diğerinde ise
2 4 Yani toplam 4 elektron e burada 6
çift Bunda ne var işte 2 çift var Bundan
dolayı bu CL2 de daha büyüktür bu
şekilde gösterdik Levis nokta
yapısındaki diyor nokta sayısı Şimdi
c2'de şöyle yaptık ya şu noktalar
duruyor Eyvah bağdaki bir bağ olduğu
için o da 2 nokta demek aslında bu
şekilde gösterebiliriz toplamda kaç
nokta var 2 4 6 8 10 12 12 mi Evet 12
nokta olacak y 12 mi 14 mü lan Dur
bakayım 2 4 6 8 10 12 14 nokta var he
Çok güzel bunda 14' müş Peki
n2dir her bağa 2 tane
elektronda Ne oldu 2 4 6 8 10 oldu He o
zaman o zaman CL 2'deki daha büyük oldu
Gördüğün gibi bana da CL 2'deki büyük
olduğunu soruyor cevap C seçeneği 2 ve 3
olacak bakalım Bu soruda ne diyor H2O
molekülü ile ilgili şimdi hidrojen
şöyleydi tek noktaydı oksijene
geldiğimizde ise 1 S2 2 S2 2p kaç oluyor
4 6a grubu olduğu için 6 nokta 1 2 3 4 5
6 E H2O dediğinde oksijen 2 bağ yapmak
isteyecek hidrojen 1 bağ yapmak
isteyecek nokta sayısı kadar Bağlarını
yazdım e şunlar bağ yaptı bak şu ve şu
bağ yaptı şunlar yapmadı O zaman onları
oksijenin çevresine yazdım Bu şekilde
bir yapı oluştu Zaten şu çizgi iki nokta
demektir yani böyle de gösterilebilir
birincisi Doğrudur Levis nokta yapısı
Bağlar kovalent hidrojen de metal
oksijen de metal birisi 1A grubunda
hidrojen ametal e diğeri de 6a grubunun
ilk elementi ametal ametal ametal
arasında kovalent bağ oluşur Hatta
farklı ametal atomlar arasında olduğu
için de polar kovalent bağ da
söyleyebilirsin diyor ki oksijen atomu
oktete hemen gösteriyorum şu şekil doğru
olduğu için bunun üzerinden
gösterebilirim hidrojen atomu dublete
ulaşır bak ortak kullanılanları da
saydığımızda oksijen 8'e tamamladı oktet
hidrojene bakarsan ortak kullanılanları
saydığımızda O da ikiye tamamladı yani
helyuma benzedi Evet o dublete ulaştı
oksijen oktet ulaştı Doğrudur cevap
hepsi doğru e seçeneği Evet güzel insan
ne yapmış olduk Levis yapısını da
anlatmış olduk sonraki derslerimizde
neyden bahsedeceğim Molekülün polarlığı
Molekülün apolarlığı diye bir şey var
orada sana şekiller üzerinde anlatacağım
ama müthiş bir pratik yöntem de
öğreteceğim sana yani tık diye kafana
oturacak pratik bir yöntem de
öğreteceğim Hatta ezberlemeyi sevenler
için de bir tablo oluşturacağım ne kadar
böyle gerekli varsa polar apolar molekül
onları da yazacağım dostum ama onlar bir
sonraki dersin konusu Tabii o bir
sonraki dersi görmek istiyorsan E benim
şevkimi arttırmanın şu kanala abone
olursan çok mutlu olurum bak kanala
abone olun dostum Bak büyümem lazım
sizle beraber büyümem lazım daha çok
işimiz var 12 sınıfa geleceksin
sınavlara gireceğiz Orada da da destek
olacağım kazan kazan anladın sen beni
kanala abone olursan çok mutlu olurum
iki fosfor bir asit kimya Bu kadar basit
bir sonraki derste görüşmek üzere hoşça
kal